Hey Youtubers it's Charlie.
This is my Arrow Episode 4 video.
Amazing Quentin Episode, tour de force Paul
Blackthorne.
Stephen Amell was saying after the episode
that some sometimes it's more fun for the
actors to do these quiet up so the column
quiet because an actor like big Justice league
things like his other big crossover episode
there mostly doing character work Quentin
in particular just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the episode yet all of the
my top five WTF explain routine a Wesley's
character because she is a character from
the comic books real quick reminder my reverse
flash ring for this week is still going on
right now all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and leave a comment on this video
starting with number five meet Liza Warner
so most you remember her as Tara from true
blood actually like the character that she
was playing on arrow way better I was in a
huge fan of Tara on true blood but the character
she's playing from the comics this is this
is really funny her name is lady cop that's
the actual name of the character now they're
just using the lies the name she's not really
doing this comic book persona arrow will do
that sometimes world don't give a character
a comic book name but they'll have nothing
to do with the character in the comics the
way she exists in this arrow narrative is
she's a dirty cop that was part of the anti-vigilante
task force the Quentin put together when all
of her came back in season one there was a
lot of season one callbacks in this episode
so she's been in the city this whole time
just as things have gradually gone the shed
and out there doing is as they are using their
special skills their special gear their access
as police officers to steal these drugs and
make money off of them and they did name dropped
slant that's the drug they're making on the
island in the flashbacks it's a combination
of heroin and cocaine as far as I know routine
it isn't coming back again real soon she might
come back in the back half because I misuses
a relatively big actress and she did a great
job it's interesting character so that she
might come back the same way Huntress comes
back and review every once in a while for
special occasions and everybody still wondering
where Huntress is that they'll totally bring
just get the gal back when she's available
in the have space for her in the narrative
I'd much rather see like Thea get an amazing
story arc to see like for new comic book characters
the season speaking of getting through the
wall onto number for Mr. terrific and Felicity
try to figure out what the hell is going on
with her mystery text if it wasn't clear Mr.
terrific is working on a number of projects
for Felicity most of what they were talking
about in this episode though it was relative
to like that glitchy text that Felicity was
getting now obviously we all know is the atom
we know it's Ray Palmer trying to contact
her and Felicity's unwilling to listen to
that last messages of his so they they haven't
started tracing down yet they don't know exactly
what's going on so Mr. terrific uses part
of his comic book character to inspire Felicity
to get over softly get it slaps her senses
you should be happy to hear something from
someone you love who is died and Mr. terrific's
big call to action in the comics was his brother
dying but also in the world of cool technology
Oliver unveils the new arrow cave call it
whatever you want it's always going to be
the arrow cave to me but the basically it
just got all the best Nutech it just way bigger
so they can accommodate a bigger team if your
Salmon ladder you have space for a car Felicity's
computer gear, we're just slowly inching towards
a Hall of Justice now on Legends of tomorrow
they have a really interesting base of operations
it's going to be rip Hunter's time ship the
name of that is the waverider which is which
is nice Easter eggs for the comics waverider
the character are we can talk a lot about
legends of tomorrow next week when Hawkgirl
debuts on the flash we we can talk about it
then, but the big twist is is that all of
her is using brother blood's old campaign
office and his old secret layer underneath
his campaign office which I think is kind
of funny, the thing is that the campaign is
going to run for most of the season and in
the back half he'll probably actually become
mayor so I guess they'll turn this office
into something else after he becomes mayor
but is not like they're going to move the
new arrow cave so they might just have Oliver
continue to work out of that specific office
also in the world of WTF reveals Laurel takes
Quentin to see Sara for the first time and
he flips out like you super happy but then
he learns that she has no soul Damien Darhk's
comment about her not having a soul, throws
to what's going to be going on with Constantine
next week next week will be when Constantine
comes to fix her ability to follow up with
Quentin you know anybody breaks down crying
he has like his Carol Peletier look at the
flowers moment with Sara for his like you're
not you're not Sara I'm in a return you to
your final rest that would've worked a little
bit better if the entire episode had been
told for the Quentin's perspective that's
kind of what they did with agent to shield
this week they told the entire story from
Simmons perspective it was still a great arrow
moment but but I understand they have always
characters that the service you can just drop
all the storylines for week just to tell this
one storyline really as good as this moment
was I think his best scenes were with Stephen
Amell he and all of her just like just having
an out what Oliver learns about Damien Darhk
so that's what Stephen Amell was talking about
when he said sometimes it's more fun to do
quiet episodes than it is to do the really
big stuff the big action sequences and finally
into my number one WTF moment Quentin saves
the day the city is not beyond redemption
but we have to start fixing it by fixing ourselves
first owning up to her own mistakes leading
to all of her roasting the ship out of himself
and his campaign speech he's been like a solid
two minutes making fun of all the stupid should
that he's done so yet is is emotional as the
episode is as much of a roller coaster in
his darkest things get it's really nice lightweight
and in an action the montage that they cut
all the different characters you see Damien
Darhk opening that mystery box that's it was
such a great device it's very manipulative
you see pulp fiction you seen seven you know
about that the what's in the box mystery but
it still so much fun when they do it based
on the markings it looks like it's something
just tied to his abilities whatever mystery
DAT that he's formed this pack with that getting
in this power let me know what was your favorite
moment in this episode there were definitely
a lot of setups for future payoffs like you
have Damien Darhk with the mystery box Sara
busting out of her chains the atom slowly
trying to contact Felicity in his teeny tiny
state there really like a few things that
threw me off in the episode Theo for instance
is going from zero to bloodlust in no time
flat but she's able to be super casual and
jokey when she's talking to her drug dealer
here is almost like none of what happened
last week happened to her at all she's completely
forgotten about it I'm still trying to decode
the flashbacks there is in a really clear
arc right now for the fun thing is is that
when he takes her to that came that's the
cave that he first went to when he landed
on the alimony Gustin on the island that's
what he says don't need the red berries because
in season one he ate red berries and he started
hallucinating his father so he's basically
giving her all the advice that he learned
the hard way like he did all the wrong things
but I'm really curious that they haven't revealed
what her name is I feel like it something
big from the comic books of otherwise there
be no reason to withhold her name even on
IMDb she still listed just as worker is just
a circle back around the Damien Darhk fathers
the father the father I want to give you a
bit of a WTF here so Damien Darhk has a daughter
somewhere maybe he put her to final rest again
maybe she still exists somewhere I feel like
that's going to be floating around for for
us to wonder about for the next couple of
episodes I used to think it was a good chance
that he might be Felicity's father but the
producers like they came flat out before the
episode aired and said no that's not the case
Felicity's father is another character who
will be a villain and is super rich who built
the use sometime this season that session
not not a very big list I would think calculator
would be a good chance but whoever the villain
is it's not going to be Damien Darhk to try
get a new trailer Q&A video out later this
week that should post by Friday but white
as way for that you can click here for my
agent to show video that I posted earlier
today and you can click here for my flash
episode from last night shark the wind so
amazing you so much for watching everybody
high five and I'll see you guys tomorrow!